hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today
i will be swinging into the latest
events in the black clover story
including the reveal of the ultimate
devil threat
the strongest devil that we've seen so
far at least in the flesh
literally the shoto todoroki of devils
asta is now forced to fight this devil
one on one
and if he fails or if his double union
mode runs out
literally everyone inside the spade
kingdom capital will die
this is no joke this is insane so let's
get into it
if you enjoy the black lover content on
this channel and you want us to keep it
going just leave a like
and comment it only takes a second and
it's a free way to support
the channel and of course if you're new
or you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video do you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications a big thank you to all
of our anime opera
patrons who make videos like this one
possible with their support
i will talk more about patreon at the
end of the video but first
please be advised that this video will
of course contain black lover manga
spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
the new chapter picks up at the exact
moment at which asta slashes naman half
using the demon slayer sword if you were
expecting ahmad to take an
l after this or if you were expecting
lilith to be even a little bit
intimidated by what just happened
you were wrong lilith simply uses her
ice magic to hold the nama's body
together
and then something happens that a lot of
fans have been predicting
lilith and ama fuse into a single
ultimate devil because lilith and ama
look like twins
and because they seemed to be two parts
of one hole
what with each of them having one half
of a mask on the opposite side of their
face and all that stuff
a lot of people were speculating that
this fusion would take place
i also mentioned that possibility in my
previous black clover videos
but now the theories have been confirmed
and let me tell you
this fused ultimate devil looks freaking
cool
but also pretty damn terrifying noct
is shocked when he sees this fusion and
it
seems that this fused the devil's
strength isn't just the strength of
lilith and amma
added up together unfortunately it seems
that the fused devil's power has
increased
exponentially meaning that it is even
stronger than the combined power of just
lilith
and amma before they fused knowing how
strong lilith and amma
already were this is an absolutely
terrifying thought
i mean they were just towing with
knocked up to this point and yet they
still
almost killed him and to make things
even scarier
this new fused devil isn't at all
intimidated by osta's anti-magic
despite the fact that asta just managed
to slice the ma in half
mere moments ago the fused devil is just
excited to have such an interesting
opponent
this new fused devil can use both devil
fire magic
and devil ice magic at the same time
so it's basically like an overpowered
devil
todoroki this has to be the strongest
devil that we've seen
in black clover so far at least in the
flesh
in their own physical body but
thankfully our boy osta
is not scared he's literally too
ignorant to be scared
and i'll explain why unlike knocked osta
can't really
sense the extent of defused devil's
magic power
so because of that he isn't intimidated
at all he's more like oh now i have to
only attack one of them
cool and you really have to love asta
for this type of stuff
he never gets intimidated and he never
quits just because the odds he is facing
are seemingly impossible asta gives it
his all every single time
no matter who his opponent is and even
though that type of attitude could come
back to bite him at some point in the
future
if he encounters an opponent that is
really much stronger than he is
this is also a big part of the reason
why we love osta as a character
he never gives up he never gives in he
fights no matter what that said though
the fused devil is an absolute beast
and it conjures up a massive sphere of
magical energy
this thing is so big that it floats
above the palace
and the entire spade kingdom capital and
it almost looks like some sort of
artificial moon it's like a devil's
spirit bomb
the fused devil proclaims that even if
asta can survive
this attack everyone else in the spade
kingdom capital will surely die
and that will put asta into despair
anyway lilith and the ma
really have a thing for seeing people
despairing and suffering
and so that seems to be the ultimate
goal here
hosta is a strong and worthy opponent
but they don't just want to defeat him
they want to break him emotionally and
they want to see him crying
in despair now asta knows that the
capital won't survive
a direct hit from that devil's spirit
bomb and so he thinks back through all
of his training and the progress he has
made
up to this point specifically he thinks
back to that time when he first
joined the black bulls and magna was
throwing fireballs
at him in that situation asta used his
demon slayer sword as a baseball bat
to deflect the fireballs asta also
thinks back to how many people are
depending on him
in this very moment and that is when his
sword
the demon slayer sword begins to swell
in size as the people of the spade
kingdom look on
and as the boys magna and zora look on
from the shadows
asta prepares to go straight major
league baseball
on this devil's spirit ball and that is
how this chapter ends
with asta attempting to use his
gigantified demon slayer sword
as an anti-magic bat that can counter
the devil's spirit bomb
his goal is to deflect it away from the
capital and all the people
inside the capital batter up boys
because
this is going to be epic the power
scaling in black clover
is now on a whole other level and things
really are
ramping up beautifully for the climax of
this
already amazing arc the fused devil
is absolutely awesome both in terms of
the design and in terms of that
incredible combo of devil fire
and devil ice magic and even with all of
that
we know that this devil is only the
beginning even stronger devils
are still lurking inside the tree of
cliff off and they will most likely
be appearing sometime soon please let me
know what you guys thought of this
chapter
and how strong is this fused devil
what's gonna happen next will osta be
able to
overcome the fused devil on his own or
will austin need some help
on that note when will the other black
bulls including magna finral zora
vanessa
and the others join the main fight will
they jump in to help asta right now
or will they join in later when even
stronger devils emerge from the cliff
off also what do you make of asta's
ability to increase the size of his
sword to that gigantic
size does this increase the strength of
the sword as well
and how do you think that this ability
is going to be used in the future
i mean beyond just using the sword as a
giant baseball bat
to deflect a massive devil spirit bomb
and because
this is such a sophisticated anime
channel i'm sure that all the talk in
the comments about asta's sword size
is definitely going to be 100 literal
and not at all a double entendre finally
what about the devil union time limit
how long does asta have left and can he
take out the fused devil before his time
runs out
and even if he does take out defuse the
devil what about the other cliffhoth
devils
osta can't possibly stay in his devil
union form for long enough to take down
all of the cliff off devils can he can
you see anyone else other than asta
being able to stand up to the devils
of this caliber like are we gonna see
some teamwork happening between all the
black bulls and all of their allies here
in the spade kingdom capital or
is asta and his anti-magic pretty much
the only thing that can measure up to
this level of power
definitely share your thoughts down in
the comments below i can't wait to hear
from you
if you enjoyed this black clover video
and you want to see more black lover
content right here on the channel please
leave that like
it only takes a second but it helps a
lot and if you are new to anime out pro
or maybe you watch our videos but you
just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
a big thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma red
haired raven
and javier rojas these guys are absolute
mad lads and disciples of
lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa algital
dr cortman the toasted chi bang emperor
otaku spidey life chanel
tungsten tarcus and you know finally big
thank you to all of our pro hero tier
patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp rathu indeora very gucci
alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokamian water joanne
garcia ted no ted
iceparky65 jessica lafond fatboy games
deadly saint and soul ray slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our exclusive
patron only discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you